So let's look at the solution
to our 4-level page table quiz.
We have 2 to the 64th
bytes of address space.
We have 2 to the 16th
bytes in each page.
We get that there are 2 to the 48th
pages in our address space.
For our flat page table, the page
table has 2 to the 48th entries,
times the size of each entry,
is 2 to the 3rd.
So the overall size is
2 to the 51st bytes.
So the answer is here, 51.
This is an enormous page table,
many, many terabytes of page table.
Now let's see what the four
level page table looks like.
The page number in this page table
is split across four levels.
So the page number is split
into four pieces of 12 bits.
The easiest way to figure out how
large the overall page table is,
is to figure out how many
innermost page tables we have.
4 GB worth of memory is
2 to the 32nd bytes,
which is 2 to the 16th
pages of this size.
So we have 2 to the 16th pages.
One innermost page table has
2 to the 12th entries, so
it covers 2 to the 12th pages.
To cover 2 to the 16th
consecutive pages,
we need 2 to the 4th of these
inner most page tables.
So, now we know that we have
16 innermost page tables.
How many page tables at the next
level we need to point to them?
Well, each table at that entry can
also have 2 to the 12th entries, and
this is only 2 to the 4th.
So, we need only one.
So this is the page
table situation we have.
The outermost page table has 2
to the 12th, or 4,960 entries.
But only one of them, the first one,
actually has a page
table at the next level.
That page table at the next level
also has 2 to the 12th entries.
But only one of them, the first one,
points to the next level of page table.
That next level page
table has 16 entries
that point to innermost page tables.
So overall the number of these
page tables is 1 here, 1 here,
1 here, and 16 of these,
for a total of 19 of them.
The size of each of these small page
tables is the number of entries,
2 to the 12th times the size
of an entry, 2 to the 3rd.
So the size of each one of
these is 2 to the 15th bytes,
which corresponds to 32 kilobytes.
So overall we have 19 page
tables at various levels,
each of which is 32 kilobytes.
So the solution here is 19 x 32.
So the final answer is 608 kilobytes.
As you can see, this is only 608
kilobytes, less than a megabyte.
Compare that to many many
terabytes of page table for
a flat page table organization.
This is why all 64 bit X86 processors,
nowadays, use multi-level page
tables of at least three levels.